Hi again Michael.
>> Hey, how's it going?
>> It's going pretty well. We are ready to do our
last lesson of this mini course
on unsupervised learning and randomized optimization.
>> Cool, what's it about?
>> It is about feature transformation. As opposed to feature selection.
>> Cool. So they can change from vehicles into robots, I assume.
>> yeah, typically. Usually it's from robots
into cars, but that's a technical detail.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. So I'm going to define feature transformation for you, or at
least I'm going to do my best to. It turns out that it's
a slightly more slippery definition than the one that we used for
feature selection but it has a lot of things in common. Okay?
>> Yep.
>> And you tell me if this makes sense.
Okay, so feature transformation as opposed to feature selection which
we talked about last time is the problem of
doing some kind of pre-processing on a set of features.
In order to create a new set of
features. Now typically, we expect that new set of
the future to be smaller or in some way
more compact. Okay? But while we create this new
set of features, we want to explicitly retain as
much information as possible, and when I say retain
as much information as possible, I probably mean, I
think we'll, we'll see as we continue this conversation.
Information that is relevant and hopefully useful.
Now, the first thing you might ask is,
what's the difference between this and feature selection.
Is that a question you might ask, Michael?
>> I was thinking about that, though I think you kind
of told me at the beginning of the feature selection lecture.
>> well, I told you that I was going to
to tell you. I'm not sure I actually told you.
>> Hm.
>> So one thing you might say Michael, is that if I
looked at this definition, this seems to actually be consistent with feature
selection as well. I'd take a set
of features, a feature selection. Then I'd create
a new feature set which happens to be smaller. And my goal was to retain
as much information as possible and we
talked about the difference between relevant features and
useful features, but really this sort of
describes feature selection as well. You see that?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Now the difference is, in fact probably the right way to
think about is this that feature selection is in fact a subset
of feature transformation. Where the pre-processing you're doing is
literally taking a subset of the features. Here, feature
transformation can be more powerful, and can be an
arbitrary pre-processing, not just something that goes from a set
to to a subset. But what we're going to do
is we're going to restrict our notion of future transformation to
what's called linear future transformation. So, let me define
that for you explicitly. So as before with the feature
subset, we said that we were taking a
bunch of features or a bunch of instances that
were in some individual feature space and transforming
it into another feature space of size M. Yup.
>> And in the, the feature selection problem, m was meant
to be less than N, hopefully much less than N. And that's
typically the case of feature transformation, though as we'll discuss towards
the very end, it doesn't have to be. But when I say
usually we expect M to be less than N, usually means almost always.
>> [LAUGH] Okay. And that's because of
the cause of Dimensionality problem. But the difference
between what we were doing with future selection
and future transformation, because this is exactly what
I wrote before, is that this transformation operator
is usually something like this, in linear transformation
operator. So the goal here is to find some matrix P, such that I can project.
My examples my points in my instance
space, into this new subspace, typically smaller
than the original subspace. And I'll get some set of new features which are
combinations in a particular linear combinations of the old features. Does that
make sense? I think so. So then that p matrix would want to be N by M.
>> Yes.
>> So the transpose would be M by N and
that multiplies by the N dimensional feature space in X
and projects it out to an M dimensional feature space.
>> Right.
>> Okay. Yeah. Pretty good. So if we wanted to write that
out. We could say that feature selection was about taking features like
X1, X2, X3 and X4 and finding a subset like X1 and X2.
And that would be feature selection. But feature transformation would be taking
something like taking X1. X2, X3, and X4, and translating
into something like 2X1 plus X2. Which creates
a single new feature. Which is a linear combination
of the subset of the. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah, but it could actually make other feature
combinations as well, right. It's just projected down to one.
>> Right, it could be projected down to two, or it could be projected
down to three Or could even project it out to a different for.
>> Okay.
>> And in principal you could imagine that you could even project
up into other dimensions which is
something that we've done before. Conceptually, anyway.
>> When we talked about kernels?
>> Yeah, although those were typically non-linear transformations implicit
in the notion was doing a non-linear feature transformation
but we even did it before we even learned
about kernels. Very second thing I think we did. Perceptrons.
How do perceptrons go into a higher dimensional space.
>> Well, when we talked about XOR.
>> Oh, right.
>> What we effectively did was we showed that we could
project the original. Two dimensional space into what looks like a three
dimensional space where the third dimension was a combination of the first
two. And then you could actually do it with a linear separator.
>> But that wasn't a linear
transformation, that c was a nonlinear transformation.
>> Right. Because we were talking about Boolean verbs.
>> Yeah.
>> But, in the end of the day it
was still a kind of feature transformation and in this
case a feature transformation where we went to a higher
number of features. And today, what we're going to be talking
about is linear transformations as opposed to non-linear transformations.
And we're going to be focusing specifically on the case
where we're trying to reduce the number of dimensions. So
the implicit assumption here, right, the kind of domain knowledge
that we're bringing to here or the belief that we're bringing here is that. We
don't need all N features. We need a much smaller set of features that'll still
capture all the original information, and therefore,
help us to overcome the curse of dimensionality.
It's just that that smaller subset might require
bringing in information across the various features. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Alright.